why is God
why does it appear that God is invisible
why is he hidden from us that's a
question that believers have been
grappling with for millennia it's also a
question that among atheist I think is
probably considered the number one for
many atheists it would seem it is
considered the number one argument
against the existence of God because
they say that look an all-powerful being
a being who is responsible for creating
all things who rules over all things he
would not remain invisible to us he
would he would reveal himself
unmistakably especially if he looks upon
it and and and and you think well if I
were God you know and I created this
world of people and I looked and I saw
this world and I saw especially the
people were falling away and falling
away from belief and there's so much
suffering and misery and pain and so
forth well then I would I would appear I
would make myself clear I would say hey
everybody listen up look Here I am
here's God here's what I want you to do
here's how I want you to live I wouldn't
pass down these truths and in a in a
book in an ancient book I wouldn't trust
human few other humans to you know
impart the knowledge I would just appear
and I would make it clear I think that's
kind of the atheist argument
and
I think even even non atheist even
believers have had moments of wondering
this I think we all probably have we've
all we've all grappled with this
question I know I've had
I'll admit that I've had moments in
prayer sometimes where I say to God I
say God if you would just reveal
yourself to me I mean can you just
reveal yourself can you come out of the
shadows just for one second and just
show me your glory in all of its
fullness just for one second that's all
I'm asking for just one second just one
second if I had just one second just
just a blink of an eye if I'd a one
second vision of heaven of the
supernatural realm of the world that
lies beyond this one if I had just that
one second that would be enough to
sustain me for the rest of my life I
could live for a hundred years for a
thousand years on just that one second
but the vision never comes it's never
come to me
it's never come the most of us and I
think for most of us it never will come
at least not in this life
why
well I think that there are
I'm going to offer three answers to that
to that question and these are not not
claiming that these are the three
answers I'm just saying that these are
three answers they may not even be the
best answers but as I've thought about
this this problem this is what I've
concluded
why is God
first answer and the most obvious hint
is that he isn't it at least not in the
way and not to the extent that atheists
would claim God has revealed himself to
mankind countless times through the ages
and as a Christian I would say of course
that that the greatest and most
definitive revelation came in the person
of Jesus Christ Jesus was born he
ministered on earth he performed
miracles he was crucified he was
resurrected and then he ascended and he
was not hidden during that time and
these events themselves were not hidden
and since then and before that God has
revealed himself in other ways to other
people and there again have been
countless stories of visions and
supernatural events and miraculous
unexplainable healings and so forth so
all of these things and you can choose
to disbelieve these signs and you can
choose to disbelieve in God and you can
choose to disbelieve in Jesus Christ and
and and and all of that but but if you
do you must admit that you are not
disbelieving a hidden God because that
is not the God that we believe in we
believe in a God who has revealed
himself repeatedly to the human race so
we do not believe in an entirely in God
second answer
hiddenness of God being so-called
invisibility of God is is somewhat of a
relative thing it's a matter of
perception you might say because in the
Middle Ages
for instance God was seen as this
utterly self-evident truth because a man
of that time would look around himself
and see God revealed in pretty much
everything he would see the beauty of
nature he would see you know he would
look up at the sky and see the vastness
of space he would see the mountains and
trees and oceans he would look at his
fellow man he would look within himself
and see his own self and his own mind
and his moral awareness and he could
look at poetry and arts and listen to
music and on and on and on and all of
this to him was a clear indication of
God's presence so if you had said to him
where is God he would have looked back
at you and he would have said what do
you mean where is he he's all around you
look around he's everywhere and I think
that that was the correct perspective
and when I have demanded in prayer at
times and moments of weakness when I
have demanded that God revealed himself
to me I could imagine God making the
same response to me and saying look
around you I have revealed myself I'm
everywhere third answer
the last two answers were not entirely
sufficient I think they're necessary but
not sufficient because the Atheist will
respond and say okay so you say that God
was incarnated on earth 2,000 years ago
he revealed himself to a very small
smattering of people who existed back
then and okay so so God has allegedly
performed miracles and all these
wondrous signs for again a small
fraction of people through the ages and
okay so you say that the beauty of
nature and all that stuff is supposed to
indicate God's presence fine but all of
that gives rise to another question if
God exists and if he is willing to
reveal himself through miracles and
through curing the blind and through
raising the dead and through even even
through coming here and being raised
himself from the dead then why doesn't
he cut out the guesswork entirely why
doesn't he just like appear to us in the
sky as this immense beautiful heavenly
figure and speak to us to all of us and
say hi I'm God here's what I need you to
do here here's here's the meaning of
life here are the things that you need
to here's how you need to live let me
lay it out for you he could make himself
unmistakably unavoidably absolutely
evident to everyone on earth but the
fact is that he hasn't why now I think
that's a reasonable objection because
it's true that even though he's revealed
himself to us as a Christian we must
admit
is chosen to reveal himself in a way
that still allows us to deny his
existence he seems to throw out these
breadcrumbs but he leaves room and
probably a lot of room to ignore those
crumbs and even to ignore him and his
very existence he could appear to us in
the sky he could do that he could appear
to each of us individually at the same
time he could appear he can appear right
before you in your home I mean he could
he could force you to believe he
absolutely could I know there are people
who would argue about well yeah but even
if God appeared in the sky I mean
atheists would still find some other
explanation for it and maybe a few of
them would I mean the most deluded the
most but I think almost everybody would
come to believe in God if he were to
appear in the sky and speak to us right
and he could reveal himself in a way
individually to all of us where
everybody in the world would believe he
could force that upon us
[Music]
you
he could so if the whole point is to
believe in nothing more than he could
force that and and in fact one day he
will force the issue one way or another
one day we are we are all going to
believe in God
one day nobody in the afterlife no
matter where they are heaven or hell
none of them are atheists because when
you when you stand before God in
judgment there's not going to be any
disbelieving there's not gonna be any
way around it so why don't we get that
sign now I think it's because believing
in God's existence is not the point in
and of itself the point is to love God
love is the point to love God and to
desire him alone that's the point of
existence if the only point we're simply
just to believe in God's existence well
then this existence where we that we
have now separated from God and where
God is invisible seems like a cruel joke
it seems like this weird game of like
hide-and-seek that God is playing with
us where he sends us off to some
abandoned corner of the universe and
then hides off somewhere somewhere on
some other corner and says come and find
me I know the whole point of life is
just to you know believe and nothing
more but that's not the point of life
the point is to love is to love God and
to desire him and I would submit that
for most of us right now on earth a
miraculous revelation would hinder us it
would prevent us from loving him
it may force us to believe
thus from loving him if you were to
appear in the clouds before all of us
right now we would all believe but we
would not all love and there are even
some of us who maybe could have come to
love him but now would not because he
has appeared
let me explain what I mean by that and I
will use again as I've used many times
the analogy of marriage and I do think
this is the best analogy that we have
available to us to explain our
relationship with God and it is the
analogy that analogy that God the Father
and God the Son both make repeatedly in
Scripture so I'm you know pretty
confident in the analogy because it's
the one that God Himself relies upon so
so think about if you're a man think
about when you first met the woman who
would be your wife think about that
moment when you first met your wife and
you saw her and she was beautiful and
she was full of life and energy and you
were captivated you were enchanted you
were infatuated right now oftentimes
we'll call this falling in love and
there are people who will say I fell in
love with my wife it was love at first
sight I fell in love instantly but
really and after and when you get
married you've been married a while and
you have a little bit mature of maturity
and and and and you start to understand
you realize that that wasn't love at all
you didn't love your wife the moment
that you saw her it was not love at
first sight you didn't fall in love with
her a second after laying your eyes on
you couldn't you didn't know her you had
almost nothing to go on besides her her
her looks which was really for being
honest the main thing I mean in the
first few seconds of meeting her in the
first few moments in the first few days
probably the first few months one of the
primary things attracting you to her was
that she was beautiful
and you had a pretty surface-level
understanding of her personality as well
but that's it that's all you had yet her
looks and you had what you knew of her
personality which was not much because
he didn't know her that well
so no this wasn't love
this couldn't be love
it was captivation it was infatuation it
was preoccupation maybe it was even
obsession but it was an entirely
emotional experience in order for true
love to develop and for a lasting
marriage to be formed these initial
fireworks this emotional experience
these emotional hysterics have to cool
down and we you know we'll often call
this the will say well the the in love
phase is ending but actually the
opposite is true that's such an it's
such a stupid way of looking at it when
that infatuation starts to cool in a
marriage where all the in love phases
the exact opposite is true this is the
now here's the part where they where it
is actually possible to be in love the
state of being really in love begins
when that initial phase ends so it's
precisely when infatuation emotion and
sexual attraction are no longer the
number one driving forces in your
relationship not to say that they're
gone but when they are the driving
forces well then you cannot really be in
love because that's not love
it's when those things kind of take a
backseat to something else when
something deeper something calmer
something more real becomes the bond
that ties you together at that moment
that's when you can really love
in other words there is really love
there is really a marriage when you get
to the point where you're choosing the
other you're choosing your wife
willfully and not because you're almost
forced to choose or because your
emotional attraction to her is so strong
think about the ridiculously intense
quote relationships between like 15
year-olds in high school I think about a
fifteen-year-old boy and girl they're
dating and they're absolutely obsessed
with each other for five months and then
in the sixth month they hate each other
but during that 5-month stretch they
they had almost no choice but to be with
each other because their attraction was
so intense and so primal and so physical
that they had almost no choice they were
obsessed with each other
there was no love there whatsoever no
matter how much they said oh I love you
love each other and even know each other
this was just nothing but pure
attraction and then when it started to
wane just a little bit everything fell
apart because there was no love there
whatsoever how does this relate to God
I'd say it relates in this way if God
were to reveal himself to all of us
right now in his glory
if you were to appear in the sky before
all of us if you were to appear right
now before you
in your home
if you were to do that for all of us we
would all certainly fall at his feet and
we would worship
I think there's no question about that
but at that point we would have no
choice our emotions responding to this
inconceivable event would force us to
fall and cower before this immense
all-powerful being it would be something
like laying eyes on your spouse for the
first time except magnified by a billion
by a trillion
magnified infinitely
and just as that emotional infatuation
actually prevented for a time true love
from forming so to would love be
prevented from forming as you look upon
this beautiful terrifying awesome being
now you would believe in this being
certainly and I think you would fear him
um and you would in a sense worship him
but if you didn't go into that meeting
already loving him
then how could you possibly love him now
how could you think clearly enough to
love him
if you were too overwhelmed by the sight
of your spouse but truly loved them
on-site would you not be a billion times
a trillion times more overwhelmed by
meeting God
and thus would it not be a billion times
a trillion times harder to begin loving
him then
and if the point of life is to love God
and not merely to believe that he exists
but if the point is to love him
then would that purpose not be hindered
even prevented
by this spectacle that we're all asking
for
I would say that God's nature is such
that that we Fallen human beings need a
certain distance from him in order to
love him because love is a noble thing
it's a it's a it is a higher thing and
it is a wilful thing and if God were so
to speak right on top of us revealing
himself in his glory
then the baser elements of human nature
would inevitably take over fear
self-preservation and so forth even even
wonder and awe not that those things are
based but they're not as high as love so
all of that wonder awe fear all of that
would take over
take over our mind and the nobler calmer
willful love would have no chance to
develop within us
so it makes sense then I think why God
reveals himself in the way that he does
with these kind of crumbs with these
hints
with little glimpses into a beauty and a
reality beyond our own but still with
that separation and with that distance
even Jesus when he was on earth before
the resurrection he only revealed
himself and just for a moment in his
full divine glory one time to three of
his to three of his disciples and only
after they'd been following him for a
time and only after Peter had already
made his confession it's it's some
important to note in the Bible that
Peter makes his confession and says you
are the son of God and then it's a few
verses after that that the
Transfiguration happens and I think it
had to be that way
that the apostles had to come and follow
him and love him and recognize him
before he could reveal himself in his
glory
you
and we will all see I think reality
transfigured one day we're all going to
see the truth in escape
but we have to go into that moment
already loving God
already desiring him
or at least at least we have to go into
it with a seed with a kind of sapling of
love and desire we've got to have
something there's got to be something
there
something that we have really chosen
and something that we could have not
chosen something that we had the option
- - to deny
if God appears before us well then
belief really means nothing at all
because we had no choice but to believe
but there's got to be love
and if we meet God having never loved
then in that moment I think logically if
you understand human nature it's clear
that in that moment it will be too late
if you don't go into the meeting already
loving him at least to some extent at
least even to the smallest extent
then it will be too late so so God keeps
us here he keeps us in this reality
and calls us home when he knows that
we're ready
we Dino's that our love has grown as
much as it's going to grow
and we're ready for the next stage final
stage
or
alternatively our life can be over when
he knows that we will never be ready
when he knows that the love is never
going to develop and the sapling is
never going to grow and our cause is
hopeless
in which case
we're finished
but either way
um we have the chance now because of
that distance and because of that
separation we have the chance to love
him
and we have to make that choice
and it seems to me
reveals himself as much as he possibly
can
while still giving us the opportunity to
really love
so that's just as I said one possible
answer
probably not the best one but it's the
possible one something at least to think
about thanks for watching thanks for
listening everybody god speed